-Our first guest tonight is the
Academy Award-winning filmmaker
of documentaries like
"Roger and Me,"
"Bowling for Columbine,"
and "Fahrenheit 9/11."
He's the executive producer
of "Planet of the Humans,"
which is available on YouTube.
His podcast,
"Rumble with Michael Moore,"
is available
on all podcast platforms.
Please welcome back to the show
Michael Moore.
Welcome back, Michael.
It's always so good to see you.
-Thanks for having me here
in your home, sort of.
-Sort of. And the same with you.
So, you've fought
for societal change
pretty much your whole career,
your whole life.
How do you feel
about this moment right now
when we're seeing people from
sort of all walks of lives,
all diverse backgrounds,
basically risking their lives
being on the street
to fight for this moment?
-I am so uplifted
by the response.
And you're right --
they are risking --
Everybody who goes out there
and marches in demonstrations
is risking their life for this.
When history looks back on this,
when they see
that literally
millions around the world
took to the streets
during a pandemic, it's, um --
it gives me a lot of hope,
actually.
I'm in a hopeful mood right now
in terms of what we're going --
First of all,
just with what's happened
in the last couple of weeks.
That, um --
That, uh, white citizens
didn't leave it up
to black Americans
to have to go
and fight this alone.
And that these demonstrations,
black, Hispanic, white,
Asian Americans,
Native Americans --
I mean, all men, women,
old, young.
It's the country I want
to live in, if I can say that.
I, um...
I believe very strongly
that we have to change this.
I believe
in defunding the police
and explaining
exactly what that means.
Obviously, nobody wants
to get rid of the police
in the sense of our safety.
But the way we've been doing it
is wrong.
It's wrong for the police.
You know, there was an officer
on one of the cable news shows
this week
saying 90% of their calls...
-Yeah.
-...are for things
they're not trained to do.
Why not when we call 911 --
You know, it's not
just a police 911.
You call, and you say,
"My house is on fire,"
they send the fire department.
You call and you say, "My
husband's had a heart attack,"
they send the EMT.
Why not
when they call for something
that's a mental-health issue,
something that's a drug
or alcohol addiction issue,
something that --
I mean, you need
the police obviously
for homicide, rape, robbery,
men abusing women --
you know, dangerous situations.
And the ones who are trained
to do that are trained well,
go through a review process
to make sure that
we're not hiring any racists.
They should be embraced
and paid well
for taking that risk for us.
Um, you know, I mean, I just --
I can't stress enough that this
is our moment to fix this.
We don't have to see another
person say, "I can't breathe."
We just --
We can't let that happen again.
We all have to commit to that.
-You mentioned how we don't
want to see anyone ever say
"I can't breathe" again.
And, of course, this was a case
where we only saw it
because someone filmed it.
You, obviously,
as a documentarian
try to change people's minds.
Yet, you, I think, would admit
and have said that
the young girl who filmed this
made the documentary
of the year.
-Yes, I said that
on my podcast last week, that --
Her name is Darnella Frazier.
And she made the most important
nonfiction film maybe in years.
This brave young girl --
she's a teenager,
she's a high-school student --
stood there, stood there
with the cops with guns
right there with her.
Anything could have happened.
And then all of a sudden,
um, you know, she --
Whatever in her
gave her that bravery,
that cool, calm, collected --
She shot that
for almost nine minutes.
No experience. No, you know --
Just completely -- It was --
She should be honored.
I said this on my show
that at the Oscars next year,
we should acknowledge the most
important nonfiction film
was not by a filmmaker.
But my point is, is that
I want all young people --
People are watching this now.
You are filmmakers now,
thanks to --
Steve Jobs had the idea
to put a camera in a phone.
I would have loved to have been
there in that brainstorming
session where, you know,
Steve says,
"Let's put something else
in this phone."
And then they're
at the whiteboard.
Somebody says, "How about a
rotisserie set?" "No, no, no."
"Maybe just
a fork, spoon, and knife."
"No, no, no, no, no.
Uh, how about a camera?!"
That idea right there may
end up saving so many lives.